the thing is with the women in the  Western Market and women in the Western  World they seem like they want guys to  Simply do you know wait wait they want  guys to simp for them okay so what  happens is when a man simps for a woman  right it puts him in the feminine and it  puts a woman in her masculine yeah and  so what what happens is is that the man  starts to be a woman and a woman starts  to be a man and so what happened and and  so I'm just saying and so what happens  is is that the the Dynamics of the  relationship get skewed and so women  while they may like because women  generally lack attention you're women  you lack attention right however too  much attention from a simp you ain't  gonna respect him